all right well these elections are
coming up in three months is the
midterms one of the candidates in
georgia is herschel walker uh people
know him as a
some herschel walker fans yeah he was a
great uh he was a great player but i
gotta tell you football is a rough sport
uh because
this guy
i mean the republican ability to
nominate people who have zero interest
in how government works or really within
herschel's case anything uh
marshall has been commenting on
scientific matters this year this is
what he said uh last this month he said
since we don't control the air
our good air decided to float over
china's bad air so when china gets our
good air their bad air got to move
so it moves over to our good airspace
then now we got to clean that back up
that's that's him on climate change
and this is what he said about evolution
a few months ago he said at one time
science said man came from apes did it
not if that is true why are there still
apes
think about it
and notice it's at one time science said
that it doesn't say it anymore right
yeah well hershel has a new book called
think about
you've it of bill nye the science guy
this is hershel walker the science
talker
would you like to hear some of the
things that he's oh i mean
some of these for example uh on alien
life the planet pluto must be populated
with animals otherwise why is it named
after a dog think about it
uh
on the earth anyone who thinks the earth
is flat has never seen a mountain think
about it
oh fossils these are the remains of
animals from a long time ago who died
after turning into a rock
[Applause]
time travel time travel is possible but
you can only go one way into the future
and you can only do it one second at a
time
think about it
uh pollination pollination
flowers can't have sex so they make bees
carry their load to the sexiest
sunflower and bust a nut in its face
think about it
over the human reproductive cycle it can
take up to six days after sex for the
sperm and the egg to join up and start a
baby
thus allowing the male time to get away
think about it
molecules molecules are made up when two
atoms come together oh man i just
realized molecules are gay
think about it
[Applause]
uh oh and the equator the equator
divides the earth into a top and a
bottom oh man i just realized the earth
is gay too
you